35 years in the making here we are the
big reunion
how can i say no we have a reunion of
three characters that have become iconic
over the last 30 some years
sounds like a yes to me what was going
on behind this scene
i mean you always have crushes the wine
tastes sweeter as it ages so that's uh
that's us on this show
you landed one kick you got lucky
so we know the preparation for you know
training in the karate sequences and
things like that but what is the
preparation for your
hair
the reunion karatekit fans have been
waiting 35 years for
and only e.t is on the set 35 years in
the making here we are the big reunion
i'm so happy to see you what was the
call that made you say
yes i'm reprising my role as ally
um i just was really excited to see
ralph and billy and john and hayden
um and josh were so lovely and so
excited for me to be on the show
that how could i say no yeah and have
you been a fan of cobra kai from afar
yes i watched um i watched all the
seasons the and uh um i was just so
impressed with how
they handled um you know
taking something that's so beloved a
movie that's so beloved and then
being able to make it into something
equally interesting and complicated and
funny
and heartwarming that's the part that i
was really excited about that it plays
on so many different
tones yeah um and just like the original
yes you know
but in like a modern-day kind of
approach yeah
yeah it's really really well done so 35
years
if somebody told you you're gonna be
playing daniel 35 years from now what
would you have said to them
uh that's never going to happen i mean
who
who you know that i really never thought
i'd be back in these shoes again
yeah and uh and what's so awesome about
it is the embrace we get
from not only the country the world
this character has become this whole
franchise and the movies and
have become a piece of pop culture you
know and i'm
i was the guy who got to play the part
you know so it's
it's bigger than we are which is just so
cool and uh
and then to make it yet still fresh
original
and yet nostalgia at the same time is
what our plan is and so far so good
it's comfort food for so many people who
grew up with those films
so it's like um you know the best uh
burger you ever had or what grandma used
to make or whatever it makes you
feel young it makes the uh the older
versions
us feel younger yeah they wouldn't talk
so we had to smack them around a little
bit
and yet it's we have such this great
fresh young cast
that is now bringing a younger
generation to the franchise yeah you
know so cobra kai some people back into
the karate kid franchise through cobra
kai and then vice versa
we are on set and we are in a room but
one of the biggest reunions
ever has taken place in this room right
just right over there if i'm not
mistaken that's right just behind us
we have a reunion of three characters
that have become iconic over the last 30
some years
and that includes yourself yes johnny
lawrence uh-huh daniel russo and
uh ally with an eye yes
aka elizabeth yes and the last time we
were at the country club is when daniel
got spaghetti spilled all over him and
johnny took a cheap kiss and she took a
cheap shot
on the alley oh yeah she got you good
yes so things are coming full circle
and uh it's a lot of fun what was it
like the first time that you guys saw
each other on set
did things pick up or they left off it's
like you know friends from childhood or
friends from your high school or college
there's just a there's something there
it's just built in and though it's a
it's a foundation so
as soon as we saw each other it was just
like oh yeah you know catching up you
know there's a lot of time to fill in
right just like the shows my first scene
with ralph on the show was really kind
of
awesome i heard you beat up a bunch of
teenagers i didn't beat up any teenagers
he walked on the mat in the dojo and it
was the first time daniel and johnny
were looking at each other again after
all this time
and it we just it just like visited us
it just happened all of a sudden
you know we incarnated these characters
again and same with with uh lisa and
ali and it was so i did my first team
with her a couple days ago
it was awesome it's just cool
just seeing that come alive and their
writers are writing an incredible story
but considering this is you know the
reunion of
you know cast members from 35 years ago
what how does it make
you feel as as an actor too uh it's kind
of
intimidating a little bit because
there's i mean it was
it's history it's it's you're hit like
i'm as a fan i'm like this is weird this
is amazing be cool courtney be cool
you're a professional you can act with
these people
um but they're all so lovely and
inclusive that
you're intimidated for a second and then
you're just in it with them so it's
it's pretty awesome oh so cool i know i
just love watching you guys go to work
it's really nice
[Music]
i'm sure ever since cobra kai hit the
small screen people were like
when is elizabeth shoe coming back have
you been getting that question out on
the streets like
when people see you i have yeah i told
you that the brakes on mr miyagi's car
were gonna go
i hope you didn't tell him that it was
my fault it crashed
i have and actually one of the reasons
why i got excited to do it is um dan
trachtenberg who is the
director of the boys i was um doing the
pilot of the boys and
he said um you're gonna be on cobra kai
right and i was like
well i'm thinking about it because you
have to be yeah
you don't understand like why is the
quran again it's like
it's my favorite movie and then you have
to do it
okay so if he says you have to do it i
know it just made me go wow i just
you know sometimes you just forget how
um how much
this movie means to people yeah and um
and so just just just for him to remind
me of that maybe
oh i should really think about that
seriously
i mean but that has that is the
response i'm sure that you've gotten on
so many vacations
from so many different people that the
karate kid has impacted them
significantly so
is this franchise something that is just
beloved to you as well
well i'm so happy that they've kept it
alive that they've kept all these
characters alive i mean really there's
no example of this anywhere in the world
taking a film like the karate kid then
then having all the actors come back
yeah 30 years later and um and still be
alive and well and then watch how
they're interacting now
so obviously you and william had already
uh reunited
season one season two here we are season
three elizabeth's coming on
what was it that what did it take to get
her to come back and really reunite with
you guys
um i think i think the show being good
helped
yeah that would be good i think that uh
um the the fans around the world sort of
uh and the critics alike you know being
such a great supporters of what we're
doing
yeah it's it's it's the cool thing to be
on and uh
i got lucky twice in this franchise you
know that's how i look at it
it's really been it was that movie was
kissed by something
beyond just you know all of our creative
collaboration
you know whether you look at patmarita's
performance and the magic there and the
and the timing of a story that is
timeless
underdog overcoming obstacles
the kid who had no business winning
anything but yet making us all
feel that wish fulfillment and that
aspirational storytelling that we can do
it as well
and now you know 30 years later being
able to tap into
all those things yet make it fresh and
and
uh and relevant for today i think that's
what drew
um certainly what drew me into the
the uh this coming on board at the
beginning yeah and
and billy as well god what happened to
you i bought my head
what was it like because you hadn't seen
elizabeth since like
eighty six eight seven about right
somebody does their research
i mean a little birdie told maybe a
thing or two but so when you saw her
like here on location for the first time
or when you guys went into filming your
first thing what was it like you know
going back to 84.
it's um it's the same thing with having
with billy
on our first scene yeah it's just
it's very specific because we share
uh we've walked in the in the shoes of
these characters yeah
for so long and we have this movie
the karate kid film that has become like
i said part of pop culture and a
strong meaning for people it's a piece
of people's childhoods
so from different perspectives we've all
lived with that
so when you see each other there's sort
of this kindred spirit
that you share something even it's
unspoken right um
or even if you don't see each other for
decades right exactly
you instinctively have a chemistry or
you instinctively have something that
you share
good bad or indifferent over 15 30
30 35 years but um um
that's a cool connection to have with
people yeah and it's very specific and
it's hard to
i guess you could you could draw a
parallel somewhere if you see someone
from high school you haven't seen it 30
years and you had a very close
relationship with
but even some more than that it's not
that you just had that relationship and
that time together you've had that time
together that has
given birth to experiences and
inspiration to people around the world
so it's kind of
it's it's sort of like an unspoken
language that you have and
uh and it lends itself to the scenes and
lends that nostalgia to the scenes
the reaction when you heard that
elizabeth was coming on to do
a stint in the series what was that that
call that information like
listen when i pitched me the story three
years ago they took me out to lunch and
josh john hayden the writer creators
they told me this story and what they
wanted to do with
as a series and i walked away from that
luncheon i felt like the
the johnny in me was opening one crusty
eye and i could vaguely see ally in the
distance
like i you know and i even said that
when i got home i'm like it's just so
strange and all of a sudden now she's
here so
um you know when they told me she was
coming out we knew that it was cooking
for a while and
some creative details and some other
things had to be worked out and so we
were just you know
but uh it was it was kind of meant to be
y'all weren't even born when this movie
came out
i mean but you know i'm sure obviously
you've probably watched the films
when you know in preparation for the
series now
you know that elizabeth shoes hitting
the set right really yes
you didn't even imagine anything i was
already saying i like
people are going to go bonkers when they
hear that that's on set have you guys
had any interactions with her
i just had my first one today oh really
yeah i met her in uh hair makeup
maybe like a week ago okay so spill the
tea i want to know how to go
what'd you think we talked for like uh
20 minutes and she was so cool my mom
was here with me my mom was like
kind of like geeking out a little bit
you're like calm down mom she was so
cool like so down to earth
we were like talking talking and i had
to like get in i was like hey someone
you know like i love adventures and
babysitting
you know she's like oh that movie was so
much fun to film on she told me like all
this cool stuff
but she was awesome it was really cool i
mean i'm stuck to see all our scenes and
stuff
totally what about you sean uh we just
had the quickest
uh interaction ever it was they're
filming right now so it's kind of just
like hey
dude nice to meet you you know i played
blah blah character and she's like oh
yeah yeah
yeah it's cool like you feel like you're
a part of history in the making it's
really surreal yeah right
it is surreal in that sense in the sense
of this movie you know the karate kid
and even the ones that came out after
that really impacted people's lives
and to just be a small part of the
continuation of that story is super
super surreal because you know
ralph macchio and billy zach and all
these characters had such a large
role in a lot of people growing up so so
getting to work with them and call them
our friends and you know get to have
dinner with them is
really weird in a sense but it's it's
awesome it's a blessing it is weird
sometimes i'll
we'll be on set ralph come up and talk
to me and we'll be like you know just
like hanging out laughing and i'll look
at me like wow like
ralph macho is laughing in front of me
yeah exactly
everyone's going to be like dang i guess
it's weird but it's like it's ralph you
know that's history kind of moment yeah
it's so weird
so we are on the set of cobra kai this
is so cool
um and especially like what's going on
on set
these last few days you all have
elizabeth shu hanging out with you guys
i know
the og alley so clearly
the original karate kid a little bit
before your time if i'm not mistaken
right
not much yeah no i'm
how does it feel being a part and being
with this like og
crew you know so cool i feel so grateful
every day first of all like ralph and
billy who we've gotten to work with for
years are
incredible and have just welcomed us in
with open arms which is so cool
and then now we like in last year you
know we had the original cobras
come back and that was so cool and
special and this has just been like a
whole new
whole new layer that we've gotten to add
which like i was super nervous super
excited i was like
yeah because i was like oh my gosh
because you know people have said you
know online things of like oh like she's
the new ally because it's that meaning
the girl i guess trapped in the middle
between the guys
what's going on here ms larusso right so
i uh i was definitely really nervous i
was like i hope she likes me but
elizabeth she's been
so awesome and so nice and even like
pulled me aside right when she met me
and she said it to me she was like
you're like the new ally and i was like
oh i feel like this torch has been
passed and i'm like okay now i can't i
can't drop it but yeah it is
so true you are like i don't know about
that with her around
i'm i'm happy to have her be the ally
which is so cool
but you're the modern day tick which is
surely fine i'll be the next generation
if i get that job i feel very grateful
so what do you think about having her on
set uh it's been absolutely incredible
because
i i happened to be on set the first day
that she worked
and i was walking past her trailer and
she happened to come out and she was
like
oh my gosh uh you're tanner okay it's so
nice to meet you she's been super super
uh loving and nice uh coming into this
and it's been super great to have her
back and see everybody together again
yeah no one has seen since the original
it's been super cool to experience that
in person ally with an eye is back on
the scene
you are a happily married woman i was
until she showed no i'm kidding
no but i mean it's like everybody's
wondering i don't know when they find
out she's coming back
they're going to be like what so what
does this mean for amanda and daniel the
case you haven't noticed the dealership
is a ghost town oh it's not that bad
yes it means that you know amanda is a
patient woman
she is a strong patient woman
i wouldn't even my husband is a huge fan
of the show and i don't let him i don't
tell him anything about it
filming ever and when i found out that
elizabeth
would be here i was like i'm not telling
this is my secret and he wanted to bring
my baby my daughter to the set
and i was like i want you to come but
you can't come he's just like why can't
it come i'm like here come he's like i'm
coming i'm like okay
and then he shows up and he saw her and
he was like
i know why you didn't want me to see her
but then he was like
can i touch your head no can't you can't
get yourself you can't she's not a
problem
but if he has that reaction you know
fans are going to go berserk when they
find out that
it's such a great payoff and i love it
and
as a as the fan in me watching their
scenes together the three of them were
just with her and daniel just heard
johnny i'm like this the whole time
i know you can't then my amanda's like
yeah come on girl amanda with an a here
yeah
did you guys just kind of like pick up
where you left off i think ralph and i
saw each other he reminded me in 86.
what yes almost as long as it's been
since the first film oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah and when i saw him i said
oh god like like it was like
so shocking and so so happy at the same
time
yeah wow hi it was just it was really
nice
it was really nice and um i think um
billy and i haven't seen each other
since we stopped shooting
really we did run into each other at uh
comic con
just this past um a few months ago but
what a place
i hadn't seen him since goodbye on the
set oh my gosh so i'm sure a lot of
catching up
then yeah you know when you're
exchanging lines on set i mean i was
just watching with like
my mouth open like this is history
happening this is so cool
but did it feel similar yeah but it
didn't
oh yeah it's like the movie never
stopped really yeah
yeah especially acting with them it just
felt like our chemistry and our
connections were exactly the same as
they were
um deep deep respect for them both as
actors
that's the one thing i really felt when
i came back i was like oh these guys are
great actors
and you are as well wow that's very
sweet of you but absolutely
but that's what matters to me now i
really like working with great actors
and
and uh and they are considering the
original
karate kid it was filmed 35 years ago
you guys were kids more or less yes we
were kids indeed
yes and on on screen there was a lot of
you know
romance scenes that were happening we
see you know love
potential love between you and ally then
also
daniel the extent of the love scene for
johnny lawrence was getting punched in
the face throwing her
stereo onto the ground there wasn't much
there wasn't much
johnny lost yeah yeah daniel and ali
they had the they did the young
blossoming love
and johnny was on the tail end of that
they had just broken up
and there he is looking down the hill
and there's daniel russo
flirting with this girl and there she is
and that just kind of started this whole
thing it's like it just we're still
fighting over it yeah still fighting to
the day
take me back 35 years ago i gotta ask
you know a lot of romance we saw
you know evolve in front of the cameras
you know between you and
ally and whatnot but what was going on
behind the scenes was there any were
there any
sparks flying there any crushes yeah
we're young
i mean you always have crushes it's what
level of crushes but there is a
you know there's um here's the
diplomatic answer
no to what you're hoping for me to say
but
uh and everyone else out there that's a
fan of karate kids
that's good i mean that's listen you're
you have a job to do
but you're dealing with emotions and
you're dealing with
playing out scenes so the more
real that they feel the more you know
the more the audience feels that so you
you play into all that so how's that for
not answering your question
all right well i think i got a little
something there there were some sparks
there was a little crushing happening
it's uh it's all good and it's still
even better everything tastes
uh the wine tastes sweeter as it ages so
that's uh that's
us on the show was there any actual
romaine surely
is this the time i mean we can have a
nice tell-all interview with you during
the reunion yes
was there any romance brewing behind the
scenes um
let's see well there's always romance
brewing behind did you have a crush on
elizabeth um i i adored lisa
and still do yeah yeah elizabeth is late
elizabeth did i call her lisa you did
call her at least we call each other by
our like shorthand names around the show
billy lisa he's uh ralphie you know
i'll be sure to say hey ralphie hey
ralphie yeah he likes that a lot but
you're
you're you know you're kind of getting
away from my questions yes
i see what you're doing oh you're trying
to see if there was like real love
blossoming on the show
well listen uh i
i no i mean
no i feel like there's something there
well no i mean i was honestly i was
i was hanging out with my cobras all the
time you know and all the guys were
hanging out and
daniel and i were separated ralph and i
john appleton didn't want the two of us
hanging out together so there was
definitely no love blossoming there
uh and you know but we all became
friends and family it's kind of like
really doing this and with all of them
it's like a reunion from high school
it's very familiar and
we shared this special moment in time
that somehow you know
still resonating today
[Music]
you guys had quite the cliffhanger
[Music]
season two things ended roughly for a
many people so
what's going to be the journey for
season three season three well clearly
they have a lot to clean up
because there's a lot of broken hearts
and broken bones
from the season two um and it can really
only go up from here
yeah uh yeah do you feel like season
three is about
redemption is that the lesson maybe
folks can take from that
well i mean in a sense the whole show is
about redemption and
individually each person's finding their
own way and
trying to make sense of their point of
view and uh so yeah there's a redemption
but i failed you i mean it's really for
johnny lawrence the whole show was about
redemption and he's trying to
you know work out his past and rid
himself of cobra kai
and rid himself of how he was programmed
by his sensei crease and
so it's all about him discovering his
true self
and trying to keep the good stuff he
learned from cobra kai and shedding it
but you know we've got chris back marty
cove's back and he's a
very strong presence in season three
yeah and he has a lot of influence on
johnny you know he was his master as
sensei and as much as johnny wants to
get away from him maybe he can't
so he's um johnny's got a lot of uh you
know he opened pandora's box when he
opened up cobra kai
yeah you know i always said that i'm
like wait a minute why is johnny
lawrence opening up cobra kai again like
he learned his lesson at the end of
karate kid
but didn't he well yeah yeah but that's
the only thing that went well for him
right karate and he was winning
championships so he opens up kobakai
dojo and really opens pandora's box
which summons
daniel back into his life and you know
increase and all this and now we've got
all these kids and
spawning of that i know and uh so it's a
lot of fun though
so we read a lot of fun uh so what about
season three
season two we saw you guys leave off i
mean
what a cliffhanger intense okay first
at the school i'm like what um
you guys were just like battling out at
the school
you're in the hospital i mean everyone's
got bumps bruises
galore um and and kind of just
it ended on this cliffhanger of a moment
where you're like what is really going
to happen how are they going to come
back
in season three so give us a tease what
is in store for your characters
in season three i feel like redemption
may be on the way he's dead
yeah me other than
um you know i think it's gonna like you
said it is the redemption story for a
lot of us
i think just like in season two a lot of
us have consequences that we need to
face
and uh you know one of those is just
being learning how to uh
recoup from such a dangerous injury you
know what i'm saying yeah i would say
in terms of my storyline that's that's a
lot of what is going on in terms of
having knowing who to trust who not to
trust and
and really going into the emotional
aspects of things yeah exactly what
about oh yeah
yeah what about hawk uh well
he's like m.i.a so uh kai is kind of
like left without a leader basically
you lost soldiers and you lost the pack
but you will not lose again it's kind of
like in ruin so you know me and sensei
crease
he's like trying to find like the next
leader and i'm a hawk is very eager
to try to fill that role you know
there's i mean there's a lot of other
characters you know so
you just never know what's gonna happen
but i i definitely this season had a lot
of fun scenes with marty yeah
uh yeah so those would be cool to watch
very awesome
are there any fun uh guest appearances
that we could look forward to this
season
no no no no no well i think the question
that a lot of people ask is like
is it possible that this character comes
back at this character and i think you
know the universe is ever expanding so i
think
nothing is ever you know out of the out
of the
cards or you know what i'm saying so so
it's definitely possible you know all
these characters live in the same
universe but i think
the ones that get pulled out of you know
the pandora's box are really uh
will be up to the writers all right so
who are some of those characters that
folks are looking forward to seeing come
back on the show
we always hear terry silver i was about
to say that one is that's the one that
we
hear all the time that one and mike
barnes
for some i mean i know why but
everyone's always like yeah
i would say it's really fun to hear some
of the what do you call them like the
predictions for our show
oh we'll be like well like yeah
these two mugs in the background of his
house yeah
everyone's left off in a pretty bad
place
so it's about building themselves back
up again finding what's going to be
right to
to build their life back up and get in
the right place again
so it is kind of about redemption
specifically for robbie because he's
basically ruined every relationship he's
had with anybody his
dad with daniel with samantha
with with everyone and he has to redeem
himself
this season and it's gonna take a lot in
order
for him to redeem himself yeah i feel
like for samantha um
season three is definitely you know
redemption but uh like within herself i
think
where she left off at the end of season
two really shook her to her core
um and there's a lot of repercussions
for that you know and
there's a lot of things that emotionally
you have to deal with when you've been
put in such a scary physical situation
that definitely
it lends itself to a story that like i
know i
can connect with as mary at different
points in my life where something shakes
you so deeply and it scares you
and it's something that was such a core
part of you and now it's something that
can be you know really scary and not
feel safe anymore and so she's trying to
redeem herself and also find her way
back to
um a place of of comfort and of safety
and of confidence i think she lost her
confidence at the confidence in herself
and her own ability to make decisions
yeah
um i know a lot of people you know say
that she caused a lot of the issues
uh but in in my opinion i think every
single person is
human we all make mistakes and samantha
made some mistakes that she has to
deal with the repercussions of so that
was really interesting and i feel like
cobra kai the karate kid it's all about
learning some sort of lesson so i have a
feeling that everyone will
hopefully learn their lesson before the
end of season three before it's all said
and done
i will say i think season three and i'm
not just saying this is the best season
we've had so far i've read every script
with like
so much joy and the season finale i
think like
thinking about it and this is the season
finale right this is
the season finale
christmas is so exciting it's never been
more exciting um
it's there's there's a lot i think a lot
of people go through very
interesting changes they always are um
but i i really do think that the fans
will love
we've got so much in this season that
i'm like what are we gonna do next
season because there's so much in this
particular season that i feel like we
could have stretched out for like eight
seasons
but it's all jam-packed in this season
and it's it's so awesome
this is a special presentation this is a
special presentation since you are the
first
press to cover this season rachel smith
i am hereby
giving you a official cobra kai season
three headband
what care of uh johnny lawrence i feel
like i have to
i put it on you oh yes oh my it's like
my crowning moment
yes a little tighter does it fit my big
noggin
now oh we just gotta get that down okay
boom you're looking good that's it bam
what's like a i need to stand a fighting
experience
no i can't say that do it that's what
johnny's saying
no it's not no mercy not a girl see
she's already covered this is tough
johnny right now so
turn it on i mean i'm a little
intimidated i don't know if you're gonna
beat me up or what oh no if only it's
choreographed
and we haven't choreographed a thing i
mean the choreography for
this series is off the charts it really
is oh yeah we have an incredibly
talented amazing innovative stunt team
uh hedokota and janelle kerfman their
husband and wife team and they're just
incredible and
yeah their imaginations the amount of
fighting that we do and the amount of
fights that are on the show
and the speed at which they come up with
the scenes and give every character
their own nuance and their own
specialty and um and then choreograph
these big
incredible takes one take of these
massive fights
yeah they're uh they're incredible i
gotta say you
you look sharp you look like a lean
no the karate is doing you well man
it's it's everything hurts but god bless
you you're faking it well
how are those fight scenes now feeling
on your body yeah no
not as good as they used to can you
still do that crank it yeah well
not today how's that the season's
wrapped you're gonna wrap that too right
no it's you know what it's uh everything
hurts now
but uh we we uh we train hard you know
to stay in as good of shape as we can
and we have a phenomenal stunt team
although we do as much
as as we can and thankfully we have the
young cast
to do more of the heavy lifting yeah but
it's we do not
you know billy myself and marty we do
not um
you know skirt the responsibilities and
they keep writing it
yeah and you all have picked up right
where you left off 35 years ago i must
say
i feel like a little intimidated to be
with you because you're usually throwing
out some
bad teammates yeah yeah you know we're
really we're yeah we're karate stars
i mean you basically are you really
really are and i gotta say
like season two last episode omg
the fight scenes were just intense and
they just kept going and going so
i mean you guys spend long days long
hours on set already
but what is it like to train for
something like that
it's really uh a one-of-a-kind
experience you know our stunt
coordinator slash
uh you know uh guy who choreographs all
of our fights his name's hido and
janelle
they do a great job in terms of really
making
everyone's fighting style really unique
you know uh when they were
starting up the show one of the big
things was making sure that everyone's
style was individualized so for example
the miyagido is
is very centralized around one style of
karate or martial arts in general while
the cobra kai side is a totally
different and even within those
miguel's uh karate is different than
hawks uh karate
yeah how is miguel's karate i would say
it's more towards the middle of the road
whereas hawks is much more violent and
you know
lots of elbows sharp shots yeah exactly
low blows so so
it really is you know all of the kudos
should be should be given to our scent
coordinators
hito and janelle because they really put
in all the hours designing the fights
and really making sure that we're
comfortable which is fun because we get
to do a lot of our own fights which is
which is super super awesome yeah it's
incredible were you in karate before
you got involved with series it's a
master yeah really
i always excuse me we both did like a
year or two
in like the first grade but but then we
went on to do like different sports and
like other
outdoorsy kind of things but then when
we booked the show it definitely was a
an upwards climb in terms of because i
mean you think stretch i was about to
say you think
like at least for myself going into the
show i was like oh you know i play
sports like i'm athletic i can do this i
was about to say but you're using parts
of your body that is
like all the kicks and everything you
have to stretch weird parts of your hip
like most of what we do i say when we're
training is so much stretching yeah and
we just lay on the wall and they just
like come like push our legs down
but it helps oh yeah it really does like
all the stretching really really does
help
because we do they try to make it so
that uh we can do all of our own stunts
like they definitely cater to like every
person's like strengths and weaknesses
you know what i mean so all of his vast
amount of weaknesses they just
they just told me yeah i only do
backflips
yeah so we know the preparation for you
know training and the karate sequences
and things like that but what is the
preparation for your
hair oh yeah it looks like it looks it
looks like kind of short now but it's
like
it's we measured it the other day it's
like a seven inch mohawk yeah and it's
typically
in like spiked up yeah so it usually all
spiked up i almost didn't recognize you
yeah no it's it's fun it's uh it's it's
a process but we get it done every day
it it
it takes maybe like an hour i'd say oh
my goodness
yeah i know i'm really really really
really so high maintenance gonna get the
tattoos you know get some cool tattoos
and stuff
i mean season two the finale my gosh
that was another level it was out of
control
the karate sequences were intense
what was the training like to prepare
for that episode in particular
super crazy no we started training
specifically a lot of the fights like
two weeks before so that way
because we only had four days to shoot
all
of that 11 minutes of fighting and it
was like fight after fight after fight
and then oh my gosh let me throw this at
you and that and
it literally was like we would just go
piece by piece it would be like okay and
now is the piece where like we learned
it all and these and we had one weekend
basically we really trained it yeah so
we had like two straight days where we
just learned it all
uh learned the choreography and then
when we got there it was like okay and
now's the piece where you throw the
punch i'm like the left punch like no no
the right punch is like okay completely
different story
all right so it's the right punch and
then it goes into this and it goes with
this kick and the roll and
i mean you all must have been bruised
from like head to toe
i uh i definitely ended up with some uh
some injuries that i
i had to get a little physical therapy
for because i'm a plus
so like i'm right here like me and then
like a bunch of stunt work and i think i
was also wearing like i think i was
wearing like little heel things wasn't i
something like that it's so practical
yeah absolutely samantha was ready for a
fight that night
um but yeah it was it definitely took
some recovery time yeah what about you
for robbie um yeah i i had a couple
ground falls that when i was the next
day i was like wow there's a bruise here
there's a big bruise here i definitely
landed wrong on that one
i probably should have taken that
differently but i didn't but it looks
good so
yes we also were all pretty adamant
about you know we wanted to do as much
as we could of our own stunts and the
stunt team was so supportive of that you
know they wanted to teach us so
everything that was safe for us to do
we did our best to do um and also we're
you know we we like to think of
ourselves as a lot tougher than we
actually are so we're like oh no i don't
need the pads
i don't know i don't need elbow pads i
think i'll be fine after like the third
time slamming elbows on the marble floor
then you're like maybe i should take so
fast
i'll take this elbow pen yeah not that
i'm like weak or anything you know
for you guys i'm telling you i will not
mess with either one of you that is
for sure mary may be tiny but y'all she
packs up my punch
honestly i love just for the kick-ass
karate it was just so cool
you know i mean just watching i mean i
was bullied as a little kid and it's
just cool to see someone kind of rise up
you know mr now you're so cool oh i know
right and it's just like
there there is a part of it that you
feel like is is kind of missing without
his
physical yeah but it's definitely
something that resonates i feel like
even in this modern take that you guys
are he was like everyone's dad
yeah you know yeah man i'd love to have
a mentor like that
yeah right exactly yeah everyone's like
oh i could beat up everyone if i had a
mystery yeah
no yeah that's not the message yeah
exactly exactly
um very cool but okay so it's been neat
to be a part of this iconic
franchise what are some things that the
guys have taught you about being a part
of this industry
fame showbiz i think just looking at
them the one thing that i think they
display
better than anyone else is just
remaining humble you know
both of them when i when i booked the
show i
you know there's so such large icons
that you would think like oh they really
have the potential to
just be such jerks because of how famous
they are but
but getting to work with them they
really are two of the most down-to-earth
people that i've ever met
you know super family oriented and i
think it goes to show that just because
they have that
sense of fame with them doesn't
necessarily mean that they have to be
jerks and i think they display that
wonderfully perfectly perfectly yeah
awesome
let's see what is the best piece of
advice that ralph
and william have given you i mean about
the business the industry and
really fame ralph has definitely you
know
been adamant with me about you know just
enjoy it just enjoy
all this and and i do my best to do that
every day just to have as much fun
on set as i can and he's just you know
he makes it so fun
like it's so funny he makes it such a
great energy when you walk on set
that it's just like okay today we're
gonna have a great day and uh it sets
the tone nicely right absolutely and and
so i've definitely like just
been focused on on gratitude and
enjoying every
little piece of this and and uh living
it to its fullest and then he also uh
reminds me all the time to enjoy the
fact that i look like five years younger
than i actually yeah
he's like you have the family curse and
uh and you should be grateful and i was
like okay i'll take it
if that means i get to be a liberal for
a long time then i will take it it will
be a blessing in the morning
i tell you that what about you i would
probably agree you just come in every
day
you're enjoying your work and everything
and it's super
just i don't know if it's anything
they've told me but just being around
them
it's it's just helped me to see how much
they've come back and
they're enjoying life and enjoying
coming back to these characters and
they're so happy to be there
just reminds me how grateful i am to be
a part of
something so great and something that's
lived on for so long and
be a part of that legacy and it's just
absolutely incredible
[Music]
what will you take with you from this
experience you know getting back
together with these guys
for this particular part um well i think
it's very special for all of us to
to see each other again because i think
it it makes you realize how
much you've grown in a lot of ways and
also
how you're still the same yeah and it's
just really intense to to feel
both yeah 35 years later did you think
that you would be here
reprising ally i did not
no no no but it's a good place i'm very
happy i did it
and it's been 35 years since the
original but now
three decades three decades later the
story line
like the heart of it still resonates why
do you think that's the case
i think because it's um it's really at
the end about principles and values and
mentorship and relationships and looking
up to somebody and how somebody teaches
you and forgiveness and
um and rivalry and um every character
really has their own point of view i
always say the show is a lot like a
prism and you can turn it and look it
through anybody's eyes and the world
makes sense
and in many ways i feel like that
reflects life and the world
reality and everybody's looking through
their own prism in a way and i think the
show is a representation of that in a
small way
and plus his characters are kind of
endearing and beloved and known yeah and
so it kind of boxes out up and then you
got some great music and
yeah and even throwback music to the
original obviously yes indeed yeah
and uh and then also just like the sense
of like
you guys have kind of modernized this
iconic tale
you know yeah it's really cool they took
the these characters and planted them
today
and yeah you know with the flavor of
yesterday and then
and in the like the world of reboots and
remakes
yeah but that's not what this is no this
is really almost if there was no movie
it could stand on its own and
be its own you know story about a guy
that was you know this
and their rivalry but uh it's just kid
gives it its steps it comes from the
head down the writers are awesome and we
have an amazing cast these kids are
incredibly talented
and talented they're training in between
scenes they're
they're learning tricks and fighting and
our hours are super long
and um but you wanted to you went around
for holding up pretty well
too well thank
really gives the opportunity for people
who grew up during that movie and even
people who watch the movie you know
to feel like they can connect with
someone else you know the character
daniel is very much a
a character who was you know obviously
bullied you know all throughout high
school the underdog but yeah the
underdog who came out triumphant so i
think that's a story that a lot of
people can
look forward to and even just root for
right and i think it's
it's a it was one of the first of its
kind so i think that's why it's so
special and why it resonates and
you know stands the test of time um for
me when i watch the original karate kid
i think
the really cool aspect of it is that at
whatever point in your life you're
watching it
you can relate to someone and some story
and um you know
either you're you're the kid you're the
underdog you're the daniel or maybe
you're
the person who's trying to figure out
their life in high school you know or
you're
or you're the mentor and you're really
seeing yourself in those eyes and so i
think it's really cool that you can
connect to so many different aspects and
i think that's
the thing that we've tried to bring into
cobra kai which has been so cool to see
that happen where
you know people from all different walks
of life can connect to a different
character like you can find your person
that you really
like resonate with i think it's a great
underdog story but
the original obviously but i think what
the creators did so brilliantly with
this show is that they've
they've twisted it in a way that like
yes the underdogs but the people who you
think are on top
or or the bully are not and it's it's
you get to see the colors of everybody
yeah just a black and white story and i
think it's really interesting i mean
johnny's my favorite character on this
show it's so great to let him try to be
good and like stay up and then like try
to be good and then like
so many people say that that's so great
so season three
we we see you at the tail end of it so
is there a chance that we might be
seeing you in season four
i don't know you never know never know
never say never
you've never seen
[Music]
you